all right now more unfounded hysterical
outrage from the far left their allies
tonight over florida's parental rights
bill in education the law recently
signed by governor ron desantis
prohibits school employees from giving
classroom instructions on sexual
orientation or gender identity for kids
in kindergarten through third grade
that's all the media mob has been
purposefully lying about what is in this
bill
and what's not and of course it's not
stopping the far left rage mob from
continuing to lie about the law falsely
claiming it bans the use of the word gay
major companies even like disney they're
continuing to amplify these lies using
the opportunity to double down on their
own far left corporate agenda as the
company now says that they're ditching
the word boys and girls labels from all
park greetings you can't say greetings
boys and girls claiming it's uh about
inclusion and get this new leaked video
recordings from inside disney purport to
show
this extreme agenda in action listen to
one company executive saying that she
wants half of all disney characters to
be
lgbtq or minorities by the end of the
year here with reaction we have outkick
founder clay travis and fox news
contributor tammy bruce tammy it's
kindergarten through third grade and it
gives the parents the rights to to
instill their values and their kids it
never says gay in the bill does it
no no it doesn't and this is really the
equivalent sean of a hoax hate crime
they have described something uh on the
left that does not exist and then they
use it to amplify themselves to gain
political power to increase victimhood
and to frighten their own base and and
then the media amplifies it even more it
does not exist and then of course the
disney dynamic is another reflection of
that but it's ironic here with uh disney
banning the words boys and girls and
they're complaining that this bill in
their imagination
ban saying the word gay the only people
banning words these days like woman or
boy and girl
are is the left now for the gay
community and for every parent out there
everyone must know this has nothing to
do with the gay agenda for people
complaining about this you know we've
spent years
through the gay civil rights movement to
make sure that people knew that
americans knew we were not after their
children thank you very much that we
were just where their friends and their
neighbors and their co-workers
this is the homophobia of conflating
something that increases parental rights
with with homophobia suggests then that
in order to be pro-gay you wouldn't want
parents to have rights to their children
this is obscene it's it's vile and it
must not stand so everyone every parent
out there you being against this does
not make you a homophobe it makes you
someone who cares about your children
and the future has it could be any uh
orientation i think there's nothing in
here about about gays or lesbians but
the gay community the organized left the
gay activists on the left
need another cause and this seems to be
it
clay you know disney's going to alienate
half the country and i'm going to tell
you people are just going to stop paying
the exorbitant fees to take the kids
there that's what i predict i'm a little
old-fashioned because schools are
failing our kids how about they focus on
reading writing math science uh and
computers and if they want to let kids
opt in on these topics how about they do
that after school and then the parents
can enroll them for extracurricular
sex education classes
you know what's interesting sean is
democrats in the state of florida agree
with this bill i've got three kids
there's no reason to talk about
sexuality in school with kindergarten
first graders second graders or third
graders it's nonsensical ron desantis is
right the governor of florida and so are
the legislators who passed this bill and
by the way for generations they have
said at disney ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls they have decided sean that
that is not inclusive enough ladies and
gentlemen now i know you're not a
gentleman sean and certainly i'm not but
i know that tammy is certainly a lady
boys and girls that basically covers
everybody and shawn did you see the
story
the story that just came out fox asked
disney hey are you going to stay
committed to the idea of prince and
princesses
every story just about that disney has
ever made prince and princesses exist in
disney declined comment sean over
whether they were going to continue to
refer to males as princes and princesses
from all of these young kids stories
remember we're talking about the
foremost children's company in the world
and they are losing their mind bob
chapic should be embarrassed for not
standing up against this the ceo all
these kids in all these public schools
they're not proficient in reading
they're not proficient in math they're
not proficient in science and are
proficient in computers uh
we're not doing the basics but we're
going to spend all our time on this woke
material and disney's going along with
this it's not going to end well for
disney prediction thank you both more
hannity next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else